how are you able to actually have deep
political discourse while playing a
video game at the same time I have a
really good chat room in terms of like
the way that people engage in
conversations like I was one of the
earliest people to embrace the
philosophy of like I am in total control
of what people watch me think that like
I have a high level of responsibility
for how they conduct themselves and that
if I conduct myself in a certain way I
can expect a certain level of conduct
from them and for the most part it's
like worked pretty well for the past you
know nine or ten years yeah what about
the actual playing of the game like
you're able to parallelize the brain
like oh like it seems like factorial
seems like a super complex game yeah I
don't actually think that's possible I
don't think multitasking for human brain
is possible
um if you see me playing a game usually
what's happening is the conversation is
like I've had it a million times so I'm
not thinking about it I've automated
that or if the conversation is very
challenging
um then if you watch me if you really
watch what's happening again I'm
probably running around in circles
because I have to think about the
conversation okay because with factorial
it looks like a lot of stuff is going on
sometimes yeah so it's hard for a
personal hasn't played the game to
detect that you're not actually love is
like you're super intelligent can
multitask or does it come off as like
he's not interested in this conversation
at all yeah yeah there's a coolness to
it like when you're not paying attention
like
if if you're looking elsewhere like
you're checking your phone you're too
cool for this conversation there's a
sense like that yeah the reality is
though is if you watch it was easier to
see in Minecraft because in Minecraft
whenever it's a challenging conversation
if you watch me play I'm literally just
running around and jumping in circles
because I have to think about the
conversation 100 I can't do a
complicated task and think about the
conversation or like that people always
joke in my chat like oh no the notepad
came out if it's a really challenging
conversation I'll get rid of the game
and I'll bring out a notepad and I'll
start writing stuff down to keep track
of what's going on yeah